[Music]
hi hey luca what's up everybody today we
are i get we're giving luca a shower
it's actually his second shower ever
today and uh we decided to start
showering him instead of bathing him
it's just a lot easier to
have running water on him than to what
we were doing to bathe him was uh we're
like scooping up water in like a a cup
and just pouring it on him over and over
and over and over and that's just an
extra thing we had to do
as we're showering him it's just very
tiring and not very efficient so we
decided to turn our kitchen sink into
his shower
every time we get to the head part he
doesn't look very much like it he
probably doesn't like washing his head
because he knows how good his head
smells and he's like you can wash away
all the smell i know it's so crazy that
two months he has this really adorable
sour smell like right at the top of his
head it's like that kind of like smell
that's kind of addicting you can't stop
smelling it it's a parent
[Music]
thing we're all done
oh you got your second shower baby
yeah
yeah you're nice and clean
you're nice and clean
yeah
yeah
yeah he's been using his voice so much
especially this week like this week we
really started hearing his voice um yeah
look at that
carpal tunnel or what's called no
something something uh cradle cat cradle
calf yeah so i bought this kit i haven't
i just used the sponge i didn't use like
the shampoo or anything this is supposed
to
help with all the flakes does this come
so nice
so cute
your noises are the cutest
thank you
but the
main event today which is this crib
finally came in oh my god i ordered it
when i was like i think i was like four
months pregnant or six months pregnant
or something like that i don't know i
was still pregnant when i ordered it
luca's now two months old we finally
caught this crib we were supposed to get
it before he was born in january and
then they told me late february and then
they told me
march mid-march late march
and then now it's april we got it on
april 6. i'm like man this company oh my
goodness
but i can't fully blame them because of
the whole like everything's stuck in the
docs situation but anyway the point is
we got our crib today which is super
exciting it's a smart crib there's a
whole bunch of features and then dying
to have this crib because
sleep situation with the baby
is
uh what's the word complicated
i don't know what to use but it could be
made a lot easier with a smart crib so
i've been
definitely wanting to receive this crib
especially because it's so expensive we
really want to use it for as long as we
possibly can
[Music]
all right the moment we've been waiting
for
us for months and months and months and
months and months i feel really bad
because that made you wait like the
whole day
for me to clock out of work but you know
what what's funny is i didn't actually
have that much work to do today i just
kind of sat around
the zipper's broken
oh look
it's jammed uh-oh
[Applause]
and if you're wondering why i'm not
helping her
i'm holding luca
he's down to sleep and if i put him down
he's gonna cry because that's what he
does right now that's why we need this
crib that's why we need this trip so
tell them tell them about um what's so
cool about this crib oh my god i wish i
was sponsored because this crap is
expensive so i'm gonna give you the most
uh
based
authentic review just like how we did
with our table which by the way is still
broken because i
haven't emailed them
it's my fault it's not faced i'm not
believing the company but if they did
deliver it broken i did hit them up on
instagram and i was like hey so this is
right broken and they were like oh
because i shall show them the vlog
and they were like oh
we love your video email so and so and
they'll help you and i just never did
but anyway yeah the reason why it's a
smart crib is because
it bounces so it actually like moves up
and down to like bounce the baby to
sleep and it detects like when the
baby's crying so no bounce and then as
the baby falls asleep then it'll stop
bouncing
it can like the attracts sleep there's a
camera on the top part right here
there's a monitor like a baby monitor so
you can see through the app bassinet
rocker monitor and crib a complete sleep
solution from newborn to toddler because
you could use it up to 24 months up to 2
years old sweet it's a self learning
crib learns from baby sleep patterns
that's scary that's scary smart
crib what else can i learn
it spots first signs of wake up and
bounces the baby back to sleep with
soothing music so basically we're
looking to replace ourselves
[Music]
but you know why we felt or i felt the
need to buy this why because
we have luca and then if all goes well
we would like to have one more child so
it's not just gonna be luca using this
expensive crib it's also gonna be the
next child that's why i'm like it'll be
worth it if we can have a bouncy crib so
we don't have to do it for us because
there's some smart bassinets you can
only use those bassinets up until like i
don't know like four months i think
four months old that's like no time
and those are i think as expensive as
this crib so i'm like might look at the
crib you can use it for two years old
here comes the curious cat i believe
lucas is not crying because every time
luka cries this guy gets annoyed he's
like meowing at us like are you gonna
handle that child or what
mom is tired he looks good
you're growing too fast no pain no gain
no bad no gain oh you scared him
[Music]
my favorite moment as a parent is seeing
his face
whenever he like
wraps his arms around you knowing that
he's fully secure and feeling safe
and that's a very satisfying feeling as
a parent that is not the face
perfect timing luca you're funny i
wonder if you'll stay if you put him on
the rocker
i'll try rocking
at least he's not crying
but we can't stand here and rock him
forever so we need the crib for
hear you keep rocking him while i read
the instructions okay
like literally five minutes later
he's back in my arms and that's how he's
asleep
oh we're one of the first 100 customers
outside of the san francisco bay area to
own this craft
nice so that means we're the guinea pigs
we're the guinea pigs usually like you
know how there's like recalls and stuff
yeah figure out things you know what
knock on wood
[Music]
so update i'll be looking here coming
along buddy's coming along
okay pal don't rush me buddy don't
it's really simple to set up actually
like so far it's been like super easy i
don't know we'll see how difficult
it'll be to mesh on and everything drew
oh it's not so difficult vlogging with
him
it's not
it's not so diffic it's very difficult
it's rather difficult to talk
no this little boy
oh cutie oh my god i could just eat you
up mm-hmm
he closed his eyes like he was falling
asleep oh really yeah sometimes he like
closes his eyes and says something like
oh i'm good
yeah he's smiling yeah and he's like
he's like yeah
yeah oh yeah somehow he looked up from
the corner of his eye oh yeah like
whenever put him down to sleep or
whatever so tiff walks away and then he
goes
and then tiff turns back around and he
goes
he's so cute trickster little trickster
oh my baby you're freaking adorable you
look so much like you man was he so cute
i love seeing casey junior oh oh
you just spit up everywhere oh man i
have my hands full it's over there
it's over here
oh here here any help cleaning oh my
gosh oh my gosh there's a lot
[Music]
tada
is it the moment of truth yes well
almost i'm setting up the app we have
the crib built out i have a sleeping
baby put the two together and we have a
happy mom and dad yes
[Music]
all right developing story we have a
waking baby and we have an app that
might not connect i don't know it says
it gives me an error code as i'm trying
to set up the profile so i'm about to
hit them up on instagram like hey so
like um hello
hang in there baby hang in there
i think he's cranky because it might be
nap time well guess what buddy
we can't set up your
profile in the app
because they haven't emailed us back
and it is a saturday so we might have to
wait till monday until it actually
functions
is that ridiculous
put you in manually
can wanna try it yeah
okay my baby boy check out your new crib
[Music]
cool
[Music]
manual mode this is sick i want
our bed to do that now you know i saw on
their instagram uh for some event that
they did they actually did
an adult-sized version of this but just
for like that event
not for like them to make it for the
masses i'm like man i want to experience
what it's like yeah
he likes it
he's actually calm
oh my gosh
yes
hi dude do you like it
do you like your new crib let's see you
don't get no flat head
pacifier and swaddle is what you need
and that is what gets you to go to sleep
these days
turning out the camera yeah he's like
making eye contact like hardcore
she's following me look
they're looking over here now
are you looking for me again
yeah yes
how cute are you following daddy oh my
god he's making eye contact he had his
first real laugh too earlier we missed
like we didn't catch it on camera but he
literally was like
the other one was that he was trying to
make words like he was trying to do
sounds like it was it was more than just
like he did something like it was like
it was different he was trying to speak
and casey and i both froze and we're
like
we didn't catch it okay i feel like
there's so many things we're not gonna
encounter on camera no i wish i could
record with my eyeball true oh yeah i
didn't show the camera yet there it is
very cool piece of tech this is where
the sounds are going to come from
without the app this thing doesn't do
anything at all
oh my god gosh
there should be a atlas mode on this to
just work like if i did the next version
like there should be a switch for it to
just start doing this at least i agree
i'm not happy about that
there's a downside
because then what if like the internet's
out
we can't connect to it hopefully it's
like a bluetooth thing but probably it's
a wi-fi thing
[Music]
all right so it's a week later it's the
last time you guys saw us there have
been some changes to this area oh yeah
yeah so
we moved the bookshelves on this side
just in the middle crib all the way to
the corner and we finally put up his
crib mobile i feel really good about
this this new change it just opened up
the space more and i don't know it makes
more sense anyway it's about to be
nuka nuka
luca's nap time
and i really wanted to show you guys my
swaddle technique so this little boy
he's a houdini
yeah and so i saw this cool trick on
instagram on like like a double swaddle
technique so i want to show you guys in
case
you guys have your own houdini baby this
is what you do you lay out two swaddles
you grab one arm
you put it under
him like this
like that arms are trapped yeah down
here i leave it like this i used to like
bring it up but i'm like yeah there's no
use then you get
this side and you just do like the
regular swaddle technique
and then you bring this up here
and then over here
really tight
bring it around
and that's it yay
he loves this waddle ever since i
switched over to doing this technique at
night like he will sleep
longer because he really loves it also
wanted to give you an update on the crib
so this crib is now functional
and we found out the problem like i hit
them up and i was like hey what's going
on this is on a saturday i didn't get a
response until monday so the whole
weekend i was we were manually pushing
the crib yeah that was not fun i was
like i'd rather just hold my baby and
enjoy my bonding time with him yeah and
so it turns out that the cable that i
connected it to because as you can see
right now like it started bouncing on
its own it's because
it's haunted it wasn't bouncing on its
own before because i connected the wires
wrong like there was a little arrow so i
i flipped it that was the initial reason
why i wouldn't do this because if i
figured that out then the whole weekend
it would at least on this the reason why
the app wasn't working though we didn't
find this out until monday night was
because i had an old version of the app
so i downloaded the app back in january
when i was supposed to receive the crib
being all excited like oh yeah i got the
app i'm ready for the crib and by the
time i actually got this crib it turns
out i had a like an old version of the
app so it wasn't linking to the crib so
once we found that out it linked and
then it worked and it's been really nice
having it this whole week i love how it
rocks luca to sleep in the middle of the
night like as soon as he starts they
call it stirring his nap like luca was
stirring and the crib will start uh
bouncing the way it is right now and
yeah it's just been really nice to have
like
like an extra pair of hands to help with
this kid you know so
that's what he looks like in the crib oh
and then but here's a downside so this
light here
it's really bright so i decided to put
this like
light cover thing let me show you what
it looks like in the actual app right
now it's like hello tiffany luca is fine
and then you click on this and it tells
you luco's place in the crib look what's
taken out of the crib all that stuff and
then i can monitor like audio video
right this is where i can control the
bounce and the intensity so like you put
it to the lowest this is also pretty
glitchy which i'm not a big fan of like
the app like if i end up going to a
different app on my phone and then go
back to cradle wise app it'll be frozen
and so i have to close the app all
together and then open it and then i can
see luca and then like honestly it's
dependent solely on wi-fi which i also
really don't like right now this is the
lowest intensity and then also you know
how there's a manual button that's
supposed to be like okay if i want it on
always they're on on manual
well this crib i've caught it multiple
times like as soon as
luca like barely falls asleep like
literally like two minutes he's fallen
asleep and luca's the type of kid that
you think he's asleep but then five
minutes later he'll wake up and then you
have to like do the whole rocking and do
everything again so it takes a long time
for him to like fully knock out and so
this crib will stop bouncing and i'm
like wait i have it on manuals like
continue bouncing and i'll just stop so
that's really annoying i'm not a big fan
of that but i do like how you know you
could change the intensity so this is
like the most intense on the slider but
it kind of looks the same but
yeah i can't tell the difference between
the intensities if i manually push it it
could go way more so i wish it would be
a little bit more intense i don't know
there's like there's a
finicky kind of crib so it's not gonna
be perfect
we are like one of the first people
doing this thing it is really cool
though how it has um like classical
music you can hear the music and so i've
just been playing it on the loop it has
like all these different classical songs
why classical over lullabies there's
also a lot of eyes here yeah there's
lullabies like twinkle twinkle little i
wasn't a fan of it like
it's it's not like
like actual twinkle twinkle little i
don't know it's like a remix version
yeah it's like a remix i don't know i
really like the classicals i've been
leaving it on that it's gonna be a
smarty pants one day you're gonna be a
classical
connoisseur what did you tell me last
night so last night casey was like man
luka's gonna be pavlov every time he
hears classical music he's gonna start
getting sleepy yeah
it also has this feature where it kind
of tracks like how long this is the
coolest thing yeah it tells you like how
long they've been sleeping yeah like how
long he was in the crib just like all
the times that he was asleep or like the
gray is when he was like taken out of
the crib so as you can see on friday we
weren't leaving him in the crib very
long so the app is supposed to be like a
baby monitor thing right where it's
supposed to notify you when you should
come and like get luca but
i wouldn't trust it or i don't trust it
anymore because after one day of like
leaving luca
during one nap i left luca and i'm like
okay cool this phone will tell me when
he's crying like i'm good and he was
like screaming his head off in the front
like the crib never notified me so i'm
like okay i'll never trust the crib
again instead i use my air pods and my
ipad and i leave it on live listen and
that's like the audio baby monitor and
whenever he's like being fussy or
whatever i'll check on the app that's
how that's how we do it because we can't
fully rely on the crib to sum up my
experience with this crib i would still
recommend it you just gotta know what
you're signing yourself up for there's a
few bugs it's a little finicky but i
really love how this thing is mesh
that's another thing too when i was
looking at cribs it's nice i like this
too it's like nice wood everything's
nice about it i was a big fan of the
fact that there's no like it's not like
a prison cell kind of slack like all
cribs are like that i'm like can't they
design a crib a different way where it's
not like a prison this mesh thing is
genius i really love it but a downside
is if you have cats i love scratching
everything you gotta be aware that your
cat might go for the [ __ ] because just
this morning
whoa
zoe started scratching here i don't know
i don't think he actually lifted
anything because i think i shoot him he
was like oh this is my kind of material
yeah because though he can't have
anything nice he poops on the couch he
scratches and you cram
it's okay baby sorry am i being too loud
it's like it's my nap time yeah let me
sleep what's your view
that's luka's view
actually it's more like this
he's being wrong oh my god you're doing
the opposite where you're about to hit
his face
hi little luca
hi baby
we're so funny
[Music]
you